[Music]
after years of delays the critics have
finally seen top gun maverick it's been
36 years since the original top gun flew
into movie theaters in may 1986 and fans
of the film have been waiting ever since
then for a follow-up fortunately that
wait is nearly over with top gun
maverick set to hit theaters on may 27th
the sequel will pick back up with tom
cruise's pete maverick mitchell several
decades after the events of the first
top gun it'll follow cruz's hotshot test
pilot as he's forced to train a group of
recent top gun graduates for a special
mission among the group of graduates is
lieutenant bradley rooster bradshaw the
son of the late nick goose bradshaw
maverick's best friend from the first
top gun in addition to cruz val kilmer
is also set to reprise his top gun role
as tom iceman kazansky in maverick the
sequel was not however directed by top
gun director tony scott who passed away
in 2012. instead tron legacy and
oblivion director joseph kaczynski was
brought on to helm the long-awaited top
gun sequel now with less than a month to
go until top gun maverick hits theaters
the first reactions to the film are
starting to emerge online good morning
aviators
this is your captain speaking ahead of
the film's late may theatrical release
several critics were shown an early
screening of top gun maverick at this
year's cinemacon in las vegas nevada
while top gun fans should likely expect
to see more reactions to the film hit
social media in the coming weeks
especially after its screening at this
year's cannes film festival it looks
like the initial responses to maverick
have all been overwhelmingly positive
in fact many of the critics who were
lucky enough to catch the film's
cinemacon screening are going out of
their way to praise the movie's action
sequences slash film editor ben pearson
for instance tweeted that maverick has
absolutely killer aerial action exactly
the kind of thing fans will want critic
charity achala tweeted top gun maverick
is a lot of fun loaded to the brim with
some jaw-dropping flight sequences tom
cruise is really a madman for some of
this tons of nostalgic callbacks to the
first and a few surprisingly emotional
beats see it on the biggest
loudest screen jermaine lucier agreed
writing i'm a huge top gun fan but i
think even if i wasn't i would have
loved top gun maverick the action is
intense and gorgeous collider editor
stephen weintraub tweeted
absolutely loved top gun maverick blown
away by the cinematography and flying
scenes and of course tom cruise's
performance of course anyone who has
been paying attention to tom cruise's
career over the past few years probably
won't be surprised to hear that the
action sequences in top gun maverick are
impressive in recent years the actor has
continued to truly push the envelope
with what can be accomplished and
performed on screen and all of the
trailers for top gun maverick have gone
out of their way to spotlight the film's
practical flight sequences that said
it's not just the action scenes in top
gun maverick that seem to have landed
well with critics your reputation
precedes you
i have to admit i wasn't expecting an
invitation back in addition to the
widespread praise that's being directed
toward the film's action sequences top
gun maverick is also receiving early
acclaim for its story and performances
after leaving the official cinemacon
screening of the film eric davis tweeted
i was not prepared for how emotional it
was while jeff snyder wrote top gun
maverick is the perfect blockbuster not
only did it feature dazzling aerial
combat sequences but i actually cried
it's that emotional drew taylor went
even further writing top gun maverick is
a profound cinematic experience and
easily the best film of the year finally
according to deadlines pete hammond top
gun maverick features a movie star
performance for the ages from tom cruise
the sequel he says was completely worth
the 36 year wait in other words it
sounds like top gun maverick really is
the complete package now we just have to
see if audiences react the same way
these critics did and we won't have to
wait much longer to find out what they
think about the sequel we've been
waiting for for more than three decades
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one